but we've actually trained athletes
you could say on the sort of academic
side of training you would not
necessarily imagine
and guess what
it improves our performance on the field
what's happening for a couple of reasons
one reason is is that you're training a
person to be more alert more on the ball
they're more engaged you're i mean
you're heavily exercising the machinery
of the brain that's controlling its
capacity to learn you know there's an
interesting thing about athletic
training
focuses massively on the body
and that's sort of uh in the level of
professional athletics that's sort of to
the peak i mean how could you improve
you know a great athlete on a
professional level physically but
they're all improvable cognitively
they're all improved provable in here
they still have a ways to go by training
in here how about smarter how about
quicker in their decision making how
about seeing more and responding to it
more accurately
logic
reasoning
and and the brain machinery itself
that's controlling learning are all
improving now i'm going to use my brain
for some other purpose maybe some very
different purpose maybe i'm going to
throw a catch a baseball
it matters
i now have a different machine than i
had before i spent all of that time in
the class
on the on the economy khan academy class
you have a different and better brain
and it will matter to you it will it
will count on the positive side from the
point of view of your neurological
capacities of course you you have this
resource every one of us has this
resource
how effectively are you using it and i
wish every young person i wish every
adult could understand that they're
probably under utilizing this resource
right
and and under valuing it the best way to
throw away this asset such as just to
accept the fact that you have some dark
fate
right that means you have no real
potential because that's who you are
what a what a silly
and scientifically incorrect attitude
that is